des images impressionnantes tournée par
un journaliste du site infos dijon ce
confrère n'a pas souhaité montrer son
visage
les il revient sur le contexte
particulier de ces prises de
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
et lire c'est pas du tout un moment de
calme dans la manifestation et bien au
contraire je pense que c'est le moment
dans lequel l'aîné les forces de l'ordre
sont les plus sous tension et du coup
les policiers
je comprends qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
sous tension à ce moment là ce qui
n'explique pas le geste qui évidemment
abusif et non justifiés nous sommes
samedi dernier en fin d'après midi
boris la victime et gilets jaunes ils
l'affirment il suit alors pacifiquement
la manifestation et réalise des photos
jusqu'au moment où il est frappé selon 8
sans raison par un policier n'ait pas
cherché je n'étais pas provoquer non
plus et que depuis le début j'étais
devant eux
en août des photos donc là je pense
qu'ils sont enfin j'étais un petit peu
la victime facile wen qui peut la
victime facile quoi donc
et ce qui est désolant c'est que c'est
des gens qui sont censés représenter
l'ordre et la loi
boris la victime n'entend pas en rester
là et devrait porter plainte tout comme
la ligue des droits de l'homme choqué
par cette intervention policière
je crois que les règles de droit qui
sont que les forces de l'ordre peuvent
utiliser parfois la violence mais il
faut qu'elle soit nécessaire et
proportionné et l'a visiblement sur
l'agression gratuite contre une personne
isolée qui était ni nécessaire ni
proportionnelle
le syndicat de police alliance reconnaît
un climat de plus en plus tendue au fil
des semaines
mais pour autant ici n'est pas question
de bavure
c'est une intervention de normal vous me
présentez une vidéo qui est partielle
par définition elle est partiale
effectivement elle est normal puisque là
nous avons des sommations qui ont été
données par l'autorité administrative
nous avons donc une charge de mes
collègues qui se fait dans les règles
contactée la préfecture rappelle le
climat d'extrême tension de ces fin de
manifestation
a tout de même demandé une enquête
interne